new album is called familia so tell us
about it and why you named it that well
i think that you know at the beginning
of this album i was having such a hard
time like mental health wise i just had
like what a lot of us the last two years
especially totally i think for me it
started even before the last year yeah
well then the last two years didn't help
yes it knows
um it was like kind of just like i think
just crippling anxiety that was really
hard for me and um i started i feel like
because i was in that place i isolated a
lot and i felt like i wasn't really
i don't know i i felt like i wrote this
line in my album thank yous but i felt
like i almost needed to be
kind of healed or in a better place
before i let myself be seen or let
myself hang out with people and be
vulnerable and be myself and i feel like
this album i relate to that yeah yeah
and i feel like this album to me was me
being like
really trusting people starting with you
know obviously it's about like my actual
real family and like the roots of that
but also i feel like the kind of family
that i made while making this album and
opening myself up to friendships and
community and even with when it with my
collaborators in the studio like
being vulnerable about what i was
feeling and um you're very vulnerable i
heard you allow them to like read like
your like journal and stuff you read
that you let them read stuff right well
i don't like i wouldn't be like you know
you have access to my my dad oh god
because i'm like no absolutely not yeah
but i would like at the beginning every
day i would like
write in a journal and then i would just
like
read it to scott and it would be like oh
that's a cool line like i feel like we
could you know yeah write a song based
on this lyric or whatever so the whole
thing for me was really like
i need to be
real and vulnerable
with the people like while i'm in the
studio because sometimes i felt like
even being in the studio like it was it
felt sometimes performative for me like
i want to prove that i'm a good writer i
want to prove that i'm good and this
time for me was all about
you know scott here's like
where i'm at the worst part of like my
where my thoughts go
yeah um and i feel like that made
some of
that made like my favorite music that
i've made and also i feel like i they
really my collaborators became like my
brothers in the studio and
starting to be open with people like
with the collaborators and like in the
studio process
extended its way into my real life where
suddenly i was like oh i could be like
really anxious and still hang out with
my friend and just tell them about my
anxiety instead of being like let me
cancel because well because they're not
rolling in perfect either they probably
got their own baggage yeah and i felt
like in my mind maybe it's because i was
young i felt like everybody just did
have it more together than i did yeah i
think everyone goes through that we all
feel like yeah and then you grow up and
you're like everybody
everyone is screwed yeah we're all in
therapy yeah
[Music]